I just binged "Euphoria" finally.
(Amy gasps)
Have you seen it?
Okay, You're pregnant.
(audience laughs)
If you watch "Euphoria," you get pregnant.
I'm pregnant with future fear.
I saw saw every frame.
I watched every frame of that insane show.
But I like that my show is kind of like
the polar opposite in terms of the stuff
that I was like really scandalized by at that age.
Like a guy being like "What base are you willing to go to?"
That was sort of how crazy it got.
It was like we had a book bag
with some beers or like wine coolers
and we thought we were like wow, we are bad, you know?
And then you watch "Euphoria" and you're like "Oh, snap."
But I really wanted to make this show to look
at my teenage trauma because that time in our lives,
nobody gets out of there without some,
without some major scars, literally and figuratively
and I think it's important to deal with that trauma
in that time in your life so that you can move forward.
And you have to watch the show
to find out exactly what we're talking about
and I hope it's an alluring mystery
because it is really amazing what your guys' journey is
and I related so much to it.
I think I've been through pretty much the exact same thing
and I'm so glad that you put it all into this show
and it just seems like a really beautiful depiction
of where your life is at now.
I can't recommend the show enough more.
(audience applauds)
Okay, you are hosting the Oscars this weekend.
(audience cheers)
I am freaking out, Regina Hall and Wanda Sykes.
Okay, so I did a little research, Amy and the Oscars
haven't had three hosts since 1987 which was,
do you know?
No.
Okay, it was Chevy Chase.
I'm impressed.
Goldie Hawn and Paul Hogan.
I'm shocked.
I am shocked.
I know.
Wait, first of all,
that seems very random to me.
(audience laughs)
What is your favorite moment in Oscars history?
I really liked this one.
Is that the Nicole Kidman?
Yeah, that's Nicole Kidman.
Yep.
Remember when she was clapping like that?
Yes, yes.
And we were all like "Why is she clapping like that?"
Like it was so confusing but I think
it was 'cause she didn't want to ruin,
like she was wearing expensive jewelry
but that was a really big one that stood out.
But also I love that so many hosts have been so funny.
I love comedians and I love
the jokes.
I remember John Stewart hosting one year
and he was like "Finally this year, we give it up
for the unsung heroes of show business, the actors."
Yes, exactly.
And you know, there have been
Academy Awards during war time.
You have a political member in your family.
You're such an advocate and unafraid
and you're so candid and fierce about it.
There's definitely like pressure
in one way to be like this is a vacation, let people forget.
We just want to have this night.
But it's like well, we have so many eyes and ears
on this show, I think it's a great opportunity
to at least comment on a couple things.
So I actually pitched, I was like,
I wanted to find a way to have Zelenskyy
satellite in or make a tape or something
just because so many eyes get on it,
there are so many eyes on the Oscars.
But I'm not afraid to go there
but it's not me producing the Oscars.
That's why I love you.
I know that Chris Rock is someone,
I believe that Chris Rock is someone
who's very important to you.
Yeah.
Like the word "mentor" might have
been thrown around, "dear friend."
Yeah.
He hosted the Oscars.
Have you talked to him about it?
Yes.
He is just such a lovely person
and I feel so lucky that he's my friend
and he's just encouraging me really.
He's like "You're Amy **** Schumer," you know?
"Don't forget that and take your time and do you."
He's just really encouraging me to be myself
and I was just talking, I was texting with Ellen
but I'm gonna get some Ellen advice.
I got Whoopi advice and Whoopi,
she's like "Have fun" and that's really why I'm doing it.
'Cause it's not a coveted role, strangely.
No.
To host the Oscars.
No, it's hard.
It's pretty thankless
and it's basically putting a target on your back.
But I feel like having fun and putting
myself out there and I couldn't be doing it
with two better people than Wanda and Regina.
I love them so much, I love the three of you
and I'm grateful that you are putting
that target on your back because we need it.
I cannot wait to see you do this and I will just be
supporting you and cheering you on like nobody's business.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat guitar music)